we're back here on overtime that's
that's the first question of James how
do you deal with a moat the emotional
aspect of what you have witnessed and
documented in your films that's a good
question because I know you and a
physical aspect you really you've really
put your knee on the line for this
beating up my body for sure and it's
really really hard to leave the family
especially my youngest daughter and go
away go to places where maybe we're
going to get killed before we get back I
mean it's that dangerous and it really
works on you and it's a it's a
commitment that I made to get this work
done and I just kind of kept going and I
have to do a little mind's control to
make it thank you for doing okay now the
rest of you goldbrick yeah what do you
think is the main reason that most young
Americans tend to vote liberal on both
social and fiscal issues well they used
to yeah they used to say you don't worry
if you're not a liberal when you're 20
you have no heart and if you're still a
liberal when you're 40 you have no brain
they don't necessarily vote liberally on
social on they definitely on social
she's not in certain fiscal issues debts
and deficits are the one issue that if
you talk to kids across the board they
are really terrified because they know
that if we don't renegotiate the social
contracts for their generation they know
they're not going to get it anyway but
they know they're gonna have to pay for
it and and so right this they're not
necessary fiscally liberal yeah well the
other thing is four out of ten young
people don't identify with a political
party and for some reason no one talks
about that because young people like to
look at issue by issue on a spectrum we
might be socially progressive which is
pretty much consistent across the
generation even younger conservatives
now like you said are evolving on those
issues 3 out of 10 under 30 or 80 is now
it that's a high percent right yeah and
I think that bodes well for issues of
every social equality
yeah
thinking we thought mollis the smallest
group that identified that like 25%
identified with formal religion
organized religion that's it it's the
smallest of any cohort spirituality is
becoming bigger yoga these sorts of crap
like Reader's Digest 6316 like over 60%
of them say they pray every day so it's
not that they don't believe that there
is some sort of force or spiritualism
yeah don't believe them or anybody that
that they don't I mean as far as you're
not opposing your beliefs on anyone else
I don't have them no exactly I don't
either
yeah what everyone's come up in position
with inside whatever helps you get to
sleep but bill your you've got inner
peace don't you I have total inner peace
I have outer peace that's how that's
what helps you sleep apnea it's that
outer peace helps you get this week with
life you know Yogi's Yoga is stretching
it's stretching honey you can add the
other dimension to it but it's really
just a good way to stretch it it's good
to stretch you know yeah especially buzz
we're getting older but now life I need
to stretch Rob let's do it right come
down dog little duck pound the ball dude
down dog yeah all right during the 2010
midterms the GOP campaign on the
platform of job creation and as a result
gained the majority in the House of
Representatives what happened oh I guess
that's really good he wasn't in the
House of Representatives at that point
thank you rob right we all mean I'm
innocent something they run on a
platform that one there they've got one
chamber they got the president you got
the Senate they're controlled by
Democrats but they have sort of mixed I
mean we're talking my jobs before a lot
of Bush's jobs were public service jobs
public jobs Obama got no help on public
that has gone down under bush Homeland
Security to Ward's slots is the
government job look it ain't up his
numbers it's like Obama no help on that
isn't that true it's like 80 bills have
been sent over from the house and sent
they just died in a graveyard there yeah
because they're all about getting rid of
regulations on asbestosis and on what
they are whole I've seen those I've seen
those they had the
know what they call that they call it
like the famous 15 or something I read
those 15 bills they were all about
getting regulation there's one day's
other the storms could be worse no this
one sort of about making sure that if
you if you're increasing regulation in
one area that you're looking for a
corresponding decrease in some other you
just want to rationalize it I mean music
loosen these really think regulations
the problem you really ought you taught
you talk to this swoop in your heart you
need regulation because I'm small most
people I think it is 8 is elite view as
the top three issues of why they are
slowing I know I'm asking you if you
think it's really the problem yeah I
think it's one of the problems what
don't think it's the single biggest
problem no but I think it's one of the
top three problems in terms of
businesses expanding we hiring people we
all get frustrated I wanted to cut down
a couple of trees in my backyard I
couldn't do it because they're like
protected but you know at the end of the
day I was like you know what maybe
that's good
so I've tolerated approach to regulation
is what you need I mean instead of just
being over callous with regulation in a
way that has ended up deterring the
growth of the economy it's just some
moderation is all where I give an
example I wish a lot of moderates in in
in in the House and Senate if they're
warm moderate Republicans amongst us I
mean we've talked about Democrats there
are have been wiped a vacant looks like
regular wouldn't gain public it's no
sugar no wait Democrats and ten but wait
no no come on again this is false
equivalency there are no more moderate
Republicans left there are plenty of
moderate Democrats who look just like
publicans it's not are you kidding
Susan Collins is not a moderate
Republican there's one loop you snow
okay we got the two ladies for name why
are you going Rick Oh in one more come
on you're out around on you're out buddy
do their everything you carry it gonna
parry me to the three the problem is
that the Republican Party has moved very
steadily to the right from since 1964
when all right Goldwater lost and and a
lot of infrastructure was put in place
to move the party right now the
Democratic Party it's you know you talk
about limpia except for Bernie Sanders
and a couple of other people in the
Democratic Party is essentially where
the Republican Party was around the
I'm of Rockefeller group we're a middle
we're a middle even after the 90s all us
all the Blue Dog Democrats in the house
walk on isn't 20 they're all gone all
those people those people are good
advice tried you like our tour a day at
all that's why did you had a neighbor a
partisan a Blue Dog Democrat who end up
speaking at the Republican convention
and that's honestly on both sides
moderates have been wiped out our to our
tour Davis yeah on both sides you cannot
say that moderates have not been wiped
out on Republicans Democrats in the
public by the way who balloons all this
they keep voting for people on the
extreme they they allow reapportionment
that that institutionalizes I mean this
is louder Hughes more well I'm sorry I
because they're louder and more bowed
out there that is so not true the
president the United States is not an
extremist no far from being a socialist
he's not even a little middle of the
road
his house alone this home for plan was
not a radical plan it was not even
single-payer lettle it was not here's
your tip here's what it was an old
Republican business from here where's
Wyatt right here here's why he's off to
the left okay it's number one I wish you
someone in terms of Sandesh well you've
invested in him so you he's off to the
left because if you look at the
post-world War two period facts are
stubborn things right the average
spending as a percentage of the economy
is for government is about 20% Democrats
Republicans they come and go 20 percent
under Obama it's now pushing 24 pacy
cause the last guy drove it
three straight years of trillion-dollar
deficits and your generations right be
the one that's gonna change after the
stimulus his but after the stimulus past
his budget stayed the same size the
following four years a lot of his budget
was Bush's old budget the wars Bush
never put the wars on the on the Obama
hasn't put Fannie and Freddie main on
the tab either I mean this is budget
gimmickry both sides keep numbers off of
the balance present time presidents have
a hard time okay FDR inherited the
depression Nixon know it forward Nixon
that the Vietnam War we afford the
impeachment FDR made the depression
worse they've got the actually the
economy bottomed out in 1936 1937
well worse no no actually when that got
better and then it got worse when they
went back to austerity in 1937 it got a
better got worse under FDR's watch and
then it got better when we got into at
some point in ears don't you aren't you
supposed to be held accountable for what
you say and what you promised
that's what's the point I go read those
economic statistics put it again you
know but the truth is Street isn't that
what the truth is remilia double that
are still unemployed we're working for a
republican hat that's the truth if at a
republican it had this record you'd be
naming airports after no no no all right
we gotta go
Real Time with Bill Maher Friday night
at 10 past bill and its guests to a
blessings right after the show at
hbo.com